you know for being called the quiet ones
they're really fricking loud the quiet
one stars samklef in' and jared harris
and what this film is about is a group
of paranormal investigators in the 70s
who are attempting to prove that a young
girl is actually under an extreme
psychosis and that she isn't attached to
some entity that's able to communicate
with her which is what she is saying
they're attempting to prove that there's
a scientific reasoning behind all of
this
Sam clapping or Finnick from The Hunger
Games placed the cameraman of this group
and we get to watch his footage and how
they react to it and eventually over
time they start to realize that there is
some more stuff going on here than they
care to acknowledge when I walked into
the quiet ones I was just hoping for
some old-school scares you know some
basic old like 1970s style horror cuz it
takes place in 1974 and we've seen that
get more popular lately like since the
conjuring was such a huge success a lot
of people are like wow we should have
some horror films that took place in the
60s and 70s more often because people
like that stuff unfortunately this movie
is just a long string of jump scares
over and over and over again oh my
goodness is someone's behind you oh it's
just your friend Oh someone slap their
hand against the window oh it's just
your girlfriend you know like those are
false scare stupid jump scares a cat
jumps out of it cupboard a bird flies
out from somewhere it freaks everyone
out those kind of scares are stupid and
the quiet ones is filled with them
somebody literally just slams their head
against a window screaming trying to
scare their friend that's supposed to be
really scary but all this is the
filmmakers have like no sound for a
while and then they'll just turn up the
volume to maximum for some huge big
moment in which we're supposed to be
startled but it's nothing to actually be
afraid about those are weak scares and
the quiet ones is filled with them this
movie has a jump-scare like every three
minutes and after a while it just became
unnerving in a very bad way because I
recognized that none of these scares
feel earned it's just loud sound effects
over and over again and I hate that in a
movie that is by far the worst part of
this film one of the really good aspects
is Sam clavin's performance he is really
good in this movie and proves after the
Hunger Games that he is definitely an
actor to watch the young girl who
actually has this
problem Olivia cook she's also very good
in the movie Jared Harris at times /
acts a little bit he seems to play
professors quite often in movies where
he's like hello yes I'm going to study
this problem and I am a professor of
English technology and I will discover
that you are in fact under a deep
psychosis and not actually haunted I was
Moriarty in the Sherlock Holmes film did
you know that yes I was I'm rich and
you're not don't get me wrong I like
Jared Harrison movies but it just seemed
like he was trying to ham it up for the
purpose of being hammy to be hammy in a
movie that he thought was hammy but was
actually trying to be the less hammy
than he thought it was that made sense
to me in my head when I said it I
apologize what I mean by that is that
the director of this film is trying to
make a good-looking movie there are
times in this film where he has some
really good shots some good scene
build-up some good tension but most that
tension unfortunately is just because
we're waiting to be startled by a very
loud sound effect and that is annoying
to me to me that's not really scary
that's just the fact that you are in a
theater surrounded by speakers and a
really loud noise could happen at any
second and you're awaiting it because
this film does nothing but that this is
not a terrible movie this is a good
looking movie there are moments in the
film that did genuinely frighten me and
there are some good performances in the
movie but the way the film eventually
concludes and the way that the story
becomes apparent is like that can't
spoil it for you but once you actually
see where things are going it's like
you'd have to be an idiot not to notice
these kind of things I'm gonna give the
quiet ones a see it is not a bad bad bad
movie but it is a film where the scares
are nothing but jumps and it annoys me
when films do that because it's not
earned you think of all the best horror
or suspense related films out there and
none of them are filled with these
stupid false scares that this film is
filled with guys if you have seen the
film let me know what your thoughts are
below on it and let me ask you a
question what is your favorite horror
film that has come out and saved the
past 5 years I'm not sure what mine
would be but there are some really good
ones there's been some actually pretty
good ones the past few years mostly
thanks to James 1 thank you so much for
watching and as always guys if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]